virgins
so that's what i'm saying the reason
women like say phrases like that is
because we're all sleeping with the same
guys it's a very small percentage of men
that can even get girls
only
yeah i
i really find that shocking i thought
everyone could get a girl
you just go to some of them clubs on a
friday saturday night they're out there
well those are the guys that cannot
those are the guys that can afford to
make it to the club just go outside
don't even need to go in
the tube
i i think else i'll give it i see i
think you're
where are these women giving out can you
name an exact time on location
i'm going to hook you up i'm going to
hook you up because
even the most like out there man he
still has to go through like
hoodles and hoops to play with women
even the even that 20 guy still has to
be on point and do things right and be
in the right place at the right time say
the right things be the right physique
um take her to the right place say write
things to her friends there's a lot of
things that are hard for you guys it is
so hard because you don't have no
expectations you could just come with
your what do women have to do to get sex
we just have to exist
i'm not saying it's your fault but i'm
saying like i empathize with men because
it's a lot harder for them to even feel
like desired they have to go through all
of this work to even have girls
interested in them where we just exist
because we have such
because of the deception that men do we
have such a guard up of what guys we do
go around but but women go after the bad
guys and then complain
yeah
so you've got that
my thing is right so with this hypergamy
stuff is that
these women a lot of these women will
get with the key players these are the
guys that you know
when you dance there's certain guys that
just smash everyone in it they take
advantage of the new girls they tap
everyone so those girls they go with
that guy
and then now they've learned their
lessons they've dated mr toxic he did
this that this that he's telling me i'm
like uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
and then they're like oh you know i want
to take it but it's slow with you
listen listen i was you know i was young
then i just you know you need to really
and i understand it because you know i
dismiss those women but
do you understand it though really i do
i do understand
because for a man
the advantage we have that's never
spoken of we have the advantage of
experience
like yeah we get screwed over and it's a
hustle but
i i get i have infinite a lot of time to
figure it out in it women don't really
have that much time in it so for me past
a certain age past 27 when i've seen
enough i'm like oh snap i really get
like um
for me every year there is a new cohort
of
young women who think they're grown
coming in and it's easy
it's it's extremely yo what you're a
predator no it's not even pretty they
all think they're like you know i'm i'm
21 i'm graduated from uni i know it bro
listen there's four of us here that
specialize in these women exactly
i know where to take you i know what to
say i know what you think of yourself
and it happens so that's the advantages
we have in it that every man is like
born like an rpg character in it we all
start on level one everyone even the
coolest guy leonardo dicaprio do you
mean as in and use because women after a
certain age are haven't got that you're
born with it's harder value women are
born with value so i have to earn my
value yeah so i'm invaluable say that
again that's what that's what no i'm
saying the more you sleep with men the
less value will you become oh i thought
you mean okay i'm not saying that i know
i'm saying that
i'm saying that i'm not i mean the let
you the older you get the less valuable
if you're over the guy was it who was it
kevin smith 35 you're undateable it
but it doesn't mean you're undateable it
means that you're less valuable than you
were when you were like 10 15 years ago
oh you can't compete for the same yeah
you can't compete for the same guy but
i'm saying men it's the opposite the
older people the same men that was
fighting one in 15 years ago you're not
no i'm the same kind type of guy you're
competing for the same 20 percent of guy
even though you think it's a new guy
guys guys
because because okay i'm 25 right i
could date a guy up to 45 i'd be fine
with it and so like even even now we're
competing for the same guy
and that's so that's what he's saying
yeah so you've got the advantage you're
25 i get it and
just to clarify i wasn't saying that
like you know women are less valuable
with age it's just that obviously it
becomes a bit harder for women because
of age in the dating market because
obviously there are certain trends right
men tend to prefer younger women there
are certain elements of being younger
that are advantageous in dating like
vitality and having a certain mindset
that men can find refreshing at times it
gets harder for women i think we all
understand that right but for men
you know the older you get the better
you learn to engage with women you're
better you know you don't say the goofy
stuff you used to say when you were like
20. no the younger women are more
susceptible to your to your [ __ ] i
was going to say i think as you get
older you you tend to not really you
can't do the [ __ ] you can and you
can see it coming like straight right
but but this is where you go back to
it's the same same prize lower value
higher price yeah and that's that's the
biggest complaint i hear from men with
older women i'll tell you a story
actually this happened to me a few weeks
ago
there's two but i'll tell you this one
first so there was this
girl i met in the club she was great she
was in a similar scene as me and she
looked very good this night i'm very
direct with my interest i was like damn
yeah you looking good whatever talking
all that crap
um
we we're having a chat on the side and
she's you know acting all coy and she's
like i don't i don't date in this scene
i was like all right all right so uh
like so you want me you know your kind
of dinner date kind of girl cool cool
i found out that girl's been with almost
all of my boys
right so so for me for me she you know
she she kind of you didn't continue you
didn't take oh no i didn't i did an
instagram i got a number i never spoke
to her again and now she looks at me
like i'm some kind of alien every time
she sees me he's like
but that's that's the kind of story of
how it works sometimes does it make you
improve
absolutely because you knew that you was
at disadvantage when she told you that
right
yes i knew that there was something i
didn't understand and then when when my
boys told me like yeah like she's she's
been with their bear are these madness
oh okay i get it you just believed what
your friends said why would they lie
why wouldn't they lie
do you not think it's the same the other
way around though yeah so like if if i
meet a guy and i know that he's slept
with everyone in this community all of
my friends like do you really think i'm
still going to be yeah
most women are still attracted to him i
mean look at drake women are stealing
his condoms that's because he's famous
and people have this ludicrous kind of
imagery of celebrities that's true
that's true but in in general women pick
men that other women want
because it's a sign it's a sign of
pre-selection
and the reason and i can give you an
example women say men are trash all the
time and they lie and they cheat well
who are they lying and cheating
i think that comes down to
like going back to their age thing as
well though because maybe when you're
younger you think about that but when
you get past a certain point you're kind
of looking for more stability
and somebody you can trust yeah i think
that really yeah because but that's
that's what happens though women below
the age of like 27 tend to date the bad
boys but and then and then they get ran
through by the bad boys and then ask for
a nice guy to pick up the pieces yeah
like why why should i have to deal with
your your issues after you've just
you had the chance when you was 21 the
chance when you was 22 23 twitter now
i'm gonna go club i wanna do this i
wanna
please babes i wanna wire for you no no
no no ain't got time for you
do you know on the count of three
everyone shout out their body count five
do you get my point
do you do do you get my point if it's
named no you're not ashamed of it
because it's five yeah if it was 55
you'd stay quiet
yeah
no you would stay quiet yes
if i was 55 it wouldn't have it wouldn't
necessarily me staying quiet because we